familias rotas insomnio depresión esos
son algunos de los puntos en común que
tienen aquellas personas que
sobrevivieron a los atentados de
noviembre de 2015 aquí en parís a lo
largo de estos dos días se escucharon
los testimonios de quienes sobrevivieron
a las tres explosiones de los kamikazes
en el estadio de francia en esa noche
pero también se comenzaron a escuchar
los testimonios de quienes estaban en
las terrazas de los cafés en todo caso
todos ellos han explicado la dificultad
de poder retomar una vida normal una
vida profesional una vida sentimental y
que en realidad ha sido muy difícil
pasar la página sobre todo porque se
sienten abandonados por el gobierno
francés y también porque han tenido que
repetir sendas veces el testimonio de lo
ocurrido a las autoridades francesas
para poder así obtener el estatus de
víctima y gozar de una compensación
financiera por parte del fondo de
garantías de las víctimas del terrorismo
este tribunal aquí en parís continuará
escuchando por las próximas cinco
semanas los testimonios de todos los
sobrevivientes así como de las familias
de las víctimas de los atentados de
noviembre de 2015